[Music]
on this monday night too hot
to handle scorching heat engulfs much of
western north america
the records being shattered the impact
on people and the fingerprint of climate
change
there's no question that we're being
impacted by the one degree celsius of
global warming that's already happening
hope dwindles in florida we never want
to give up hope
but we also understand that a lot of
time is going by the search for bodies
and for answers in that collapsed condo
canadians among the dozens unaccounted
for
plus new insight into what caused that
deadly canadian military helicopter
crash off greece
and go habs go hockey loving canadians
hanging their stanley cup hopes
on montreal
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the extreme heat baking a
huge chunk of western north america
the pacific northwest and stretching
across into western canada
is in the grip of a record-setting heat
wave and it's not even july yet
tens of millions of people are caught in
it heat warnings are in place from
british columbia to western manitoba and
into parts of the northwest territories
and yukon
south of the border washington state
oregon nevada
and california are also under extreme
heat warnings right now
this level of heat for such a long
period of time is unprecedented
dozens of temperature records have been
broken the village of litton bc reached
46.6 degrees celsius yesterday that's a
new record
in canada it's extreme weather like this
that climate
scientists warn is becoming more common
we'll have more on that in just a moment
but we begin with robin gill and our top
story on the
impact of these dangerously high
temperatures
linton bc isn't just the hot spot in
canada we've been the hottest
place in canada that's where we're
called the hotspot it's the hottest
place in the country
ever it's one of the hottest days on
record probably
actually it's on track to break the
national temperature record for a second
day
abbotsford bc is expected to hit 50
degrees with the humadex i think this
will be the hottest i've ever
seen it a heat dome is trapping hot
sticky air over much of british columbia
the province only gets this oppressive
sweltering weather for a few days in
july or
august but not like this and it's only
june
so the malls are busy for those needing
to cool off it's pretty rough
especially trying to go to sleep it's
too hot to stay home
for those stuck at home paramedics are
experiencing a 25
percent increase in calls for heat
related illnesses heat stroke is it can
be a medical emergency and
and people aren't they've been not out
and about so we're seeing earlier than
normal
heat waves that are unprecedented
this is a way to beat the heat it may
look like the kids are playing hooky but
classes have been canceled because of
the risk of heat stroke at recess
we were still wondering whether or not
we should bring him if we would send him
anyway
so they kind of made the decision for us
it's too hot in the kitchen so
restaurants are cutting their staff
loose for the day
priority for us is our staff so
everybody had the day off today just to
stay home and be safe
the mountains nearby aren't a haven from
the heat the glacier is melting faster
than expected and the rivers are rising
bringing the risk of flash floods this
is pretty unusual to have it with runoff
usually it's associated with heavy rains
the blue skies over bc's farming
community have replaced the rainy june
gloom that is the norm this year
and the crops are taking a hit we've had
some pretty cold wet
dunes the last few years and this june
is just
so much heat a lot more days approaching
40 degrees
bc hydro the province's power utility
says even electricity records are being
broken because of the demand to power
air conditioning and fans and that has
led to power outages in the vancouver
area
keep in mind that 60 percent of the
people in british columbia don't even
have air conditioning
and if they did that would be a greater
toll on the grid
donna robin gill in burnaby b.c
thanks climate scientists are
increasingly concerned that global
heating is happening so fast it could
lead to cascading effects that will be
hard to recover from
earlier this month a leaked draft report
from the international panel on climate
change warned
of a series of thresholds beyond which
recovery from climate breakdown may
become
impossible well to help connect the dots
between this latest heat wave and the
fingerprint of climate change i'm joined
by noah diffenbaugh
he is a climate scientist at stanford
university
noah you're in california i think now
42 of 58 counties are in drought
conditions
extreme weather events like this are
talked about a lot often it's just
one-offs that we have to endure until
things get back to normal
is that how we should be looking at this
latest heat wave
well we're now in a climate where these
kinds of extreme events
are much more likely and much more
severe
and the the conditions right now are a
great example
uh what's happening in bc and oregon and
washington and northern california we
have
the kind of atmospheric pattern that
produces heat waves
but it's a very severe version of that
and it's producing very severe heat we
have
a lot of evidence now that when these
weather patterns do occur they produce
more severe heat and
and a broader more greater spatial area
of severe heat
and that's one of many kinds of extremes
that we have clear evidence
are increasing in in frequency and
severity around the world
can you say i think california is in
effectively a new climate
are are we approaching a threshold
well california's clearly in a climate
that's different from the climate
uh of 50 or 100 years ago when our
water infrastructure and water
management systems were designed and
built
it's a climate where we're much more
likely to have
protracted warm dry periods with
more severe drought more severe wildfire
conditions
and to still have those periods
punctuated by
wet conditions but wet conditions that
produce much more runoff
and flood risk as a result of the uh the
the much less reliable snowpack that we
have now
uh because of of the global warming
that's already happened so it's very
clear that
that california and much of western
north america are in a new climate
uh it's a it's a climate that continues
to change
you know the takeaway for some people
when they hear this is that we're doomed
anyway so what's the point
what do you say to those people even if
the
if the paris agreement is successful
holding the global temperature below
two degrees uh is still more global
warming and climate change than we've
already had
failing to hit those uh un paris goals
means three degrees of global warming
or more there's no question that that
will be more severe than what we're
already experiencing now
uh so really uh you know dealing with
climate change
really means uh finding uh ways to both
uh
you know supply the the energy needs of
the world
uh while also uh limiting the amount of
global warming and we know that that
requires
uh reducing emissions and then also
adapting not just to the climate change
that's already happened but to the
to the climate change that will occur in
the future
noah diffenbaugh at stanford university
thanks
like many canadians living through
covert 19
over a very long year made me step back
and reflect on what matters to me most
it's quite simple two things
my kids and climate change
that is liberal mp and minister of
infrastructure catherine mckenna
announcing today she's leaving politics
mckenna was also environment minister
she handled the trudeau government's
national climate action plan including
imposing a price on carbon emissions
david aiken is with me from ottawa david
most mps never make it into cabinet
mckenna had a seat at the table since
she got elected
six years ago what more did she say
about why she's giving it up
it was definitely the kids donna she
came back to that time and time again
three school age daughters one about to
go to university
i don't have many years left with them
at home
and i want to spend more time with them
mckenna also resisted any suggestions
she had to leave the trudeau cabinet
to better focus on fighting climate
change 100 percent
no mckenna is also one of a handful of
female parliamentarians
that has withstood a tremendous amount
of gender-specific abuse both on social
media
but also from fellow parliamentarians
former conservative mp
jerry ritz once called her climate
barbie
that was a phrase that ritz picked up
from far right websites
ritz would apologize but the abuse would
continue and even resulted in vandals
attacking mckenna's office
that's just noise the people
want you to stop doing what you're doing
they want you to back down
and guess what we didn't back down on
price on pollution we doubled down
mckenna was adamant she was not being
bullied out of politics and in fact
urged more women and girls to run for
office do it
and when you do it don't be afraid to
run like a girl
and i'll be there cheering you on still
the experience mckenna and others have
had
can be a significant barrier for women
considering entry
into politics in her press conference
today she encouraged young women and
girls to get involved in politics and i
agree
they should be there and they should
take up space but we need
political parties and others in the
political community to ensure that
they're safe at work
otherwise they won't stay now mckenna is
not stepping aside as infrastructure
minister
she's offered to stay on in that role so
long as prime minister trudeau wants to
keep her in that job
or at least until the 44th general
election
donna david there's this lingering
question that former bank governor mark
carney might need a riding to run in
and mckenna's is it is there anything
concrete to back that up
well there certainly are a lot of
liberals who would like to see mark
carney run
somewhere in ottawa but to be honest
we're not even clear if carney himself
wants to run and kearney wasn't speaking
to reporters today
in any event mckenna's riding of ottawa
center has some pretty deep
ndp routes it leans to the left it's ed
broadband sold riding for example
and mckenna herself had to unseat a very
popular
new democrat incumbent when she first
won in 2015 and
one more thing the provincial riding of
ottawa center which
happens to be the riding that the
parliament buildings are in it's also
ndp so the fact that mckenna will not be
on the ballot
definitely puts this riding into play
and i can tell you the ndp is already
scheming
to retake it donna okay david
thanks in florida people living in
concrete high-rises are wondering about
the structure and the safety of their
buildings
the governor of florida vows to find out
what caused the 12-story condo in
surfside to collapse an
engineering report in 2018 warned of
serious structural flaws in the concrete
for now though the focus is still on
search and rescue though
hope of finding survivors is fading
11 people are now confirmed dead 150
are still unaccounted for jackson prosko
reports from florida
tonight answers are somewhere under the
rubble
where rescuers continue to dig often by
hand
finding only the smallest glimmers of
hope we're going to continue and
work ceaselessly to exhaust every
possible option in our search i repeat
the search and rescue operation
continues
in the pile of shattered concrete and
reinforced steel
searchers have found voids that could be
big enough for people
so far there are no signs of life hope
is what keeps everybody going
firefighters like maggie castro
regularly brief distraught families at a
nearby hotel
where buses continue to shuttle
relatives to and from the site
so they can look pray and understand for
some of them
they saw what they needed to see to
perhaps start processing
information that has been difficult to
accept up to this point
four canadians are among the 150 people
missing
information is scarce for almost every
single affected family
searchers recovered photos and a
birthday card belonging to 92 year old
hilda noriega
that's all they found my grandmother she
definitely
was a very powerful sword a very
powerful soul
and if she's underneath that rubble
alive it'll be a miracle of the ages
and if she's not i know that her soul is
in heaven
miracles happen and whenever we came we
find and we seem miracle
rescue workers from as far away as
israel have joined the search at the
request of families
bringing expertise and hoping to bring
comfort by honoring the traditions of
the town's large
jewish community in the end of the day
they would like to close the story and
we're here to help
and to try to try them to do it in the
right way
each passing minute narrows the window
for successful rescue
searchers say the rubble is so
precarious they simply cannot work
any faster it's heartbreaking you know
i mean i just had to take a knee and
just think about the families
that are waiting jackson the cause
is of course on everyone's mind there
was an engineer's report in 2018
pointing to problems with the concrete
in the building what more do we know
well donna that report warned of major
structural problems yet
one month later the chief building
official from surfside met with the
condo association
and told them that the building looked
fine something just isn't adding up
about
that and the mayor of surfside says that
an investigation will need to happen
in time he's ordered all documents
related to that building to be made
public immediately
says an investigation will happen when
search and rescue concludes
and donna tonight those victims families
they're headed back to the scene for
more private visitations to that site
all right jackson proskow in surfside
florida thanks
reflection instead of celebration coming
up
rethinking how we mark canada day
i want to be able to wish everyone a
happy canada day
but i cannot this year canada day
should be nothing more than a day of
reflection
i will not celebrate the birth of a
nation
that destroyed our children instead
that is ontario mpp seoul mamakwa there
is lots of discussion about canada day
this year whether we should reflect on
the past
rather than celebrate there are a range
of views a legend poll conducted for
post media asked do you feel with all
the questions about canada and its
historical record
it would be best to cancel canada day
this year 77
of respondents to this poll said no
though it was done before the discovery
on the cowise's first nation of up to
751
unmarked graves heather urex west is in
the nearby city of melville saskatchewan
tonight
where the city council has decided now
is not the time to hold a big canada day
celebration
roland crowe began attending the
maryvale residential school
as a day scholar when he was just seven
years old
if we asked a question we would be just
severely
disciplined and when i say severely
disciplined we would be beaten
when the kawasa's first nation announced
it had discovered 751
unmarked graves near the site of the
maryvale school
crowe says he wasn't surprised it's why
he says
he will not be celebrating on july 1st
personally i
i won't be dancing in the streets
celebrating canada day
i i feel better about spending time
in one of our own communities
looking looking back at the past as
little as we can
near the kawasa's first nation the city
of melville saskatchewan
has decided to cancel its usual canada
day parade and fireworks display this
year as well
many members of the kawasa's first
nation work or go to school in this city
the mayor says it felt like the right
thing to do
we could not celebrate when our neighbor
when the people we know that of our
community of our
extended community are are hurting our
suffering
are grieving instead the mayor says
residents are asked to put a candle or
an
orange shirt in their window as a way to
honor the children who died in
residential schools
honestly i think it's a good choice like
just
with everything going on i think it's a
good choice that they're actually
canceling it
i'm a little bit disappointed i don't
believe in changing a holiday
for something that's historic
and relevant to our community
canada celebrations have also been
cancelled in a number of cities across
the country
from victoria to halifax for survivors
like crow
the show of solidarity means a lot i
think that's
that's very kind of them and it's a show
of respect of
the abuse we've taken and and i command
them for it
the kawasa's first nation has asked for
privacy this week as it resumes the
survey of the burial site
it says it wants to ensure that no grave
sites
are missed before proceeding with the
work
of identifying all that are buried there
donna
heather urex west in melville
saskatchewan thanks
still ahead a new report on the cause of
that deadly military helicopter crash
off greece
a software glitch is being linked to the
deadly helicopter crash that killed six
canadian forces members off the coast of
greece last year
a new report suggests the crash of the
ch-148 cyclone helicopter might have
been prevented
if the pilots were given better clearer
instruction
and training it says the accident was
the result of a number of factors
including
aircraft manuals that contained
information that may have been confusing
or misleading
manual inputs to flight controls
overrode the automation system
and the helicopter crashed into the
ocean while attempting to return
to hmcs fredericton
the corgi has spoken next haves fans
revved up for the stanley cup final
a lot of canadian hockey fans are hoping
this picture gets an update
1993 was the last time the montreal
canadiens won
the stanley cup so long ago plenty of
habs fans
weren't even alive well the team's got
another chance now to win their
24th stanley cup game one of the final
against the tampa bay lightning is
tonight in tampa
as eric sorenson reports getting this
far hasn't been easy
it is a happy coincidence that as the
montreal canadiens make an improbable
challenge for the stanley cup
pandemic restrictions have eased enough
to allow for collective enthusiasm
young fans are brimming with optimism i
hope they win
and they're going to win do you think so
yes yet the canadians were the worst of
16 teams to make the playoffs
they were hard hit by the pandemic the
coach got coveted and is still waiting
to be allowed back behind the bench
it's hard to fathom montreal even got
this far i'll appreciate everything
after
when we're done especially if we win
there was a time when there was no if we
win in montreal
here is number 19 larry robinson from
canadian drives to scintillating saves
the halcyon days when the habs barely
had room for another stanley cup banner
canadian base clubs dominated pro hockey
for
won the decades cup for the fourth
consecutive time
from the original six teams in 1940
through expansion
canadian teams won 35 stanley cups in a
span of 50 years
led by montreal's 19 championships
followed by toronto
edmonton and calgary in the last 30
years though
the stanley cup was one north of the
border once
and that was montreal along 28 years ago
a lot has changed since then whether
lower taxes or better weather
tampa epitomizes the now talent-rich
teams south of the border
but there is something about this
montreal team led by carrie price
that's reminiscent of the year patrick
wah backstop the habs to their last
stanley cup it's really been a
remarkable run the games just seem like
a team of destiny right now
this is something that nobody expected
was similar in 93 when they won the cup
we're just trying to make our
our own story here players like joel
edmondson sense something special
and so do fans that the most dominant
franchise in hockey history
can somehow also be a cinderella story
eric sorensen global news
that is global national for this monday
i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is reed lake
territorial park in the northwest
territories
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye